>> Laura: ONCE AGAIN, IT'S
CRUNCH TIME I CAPITOL HILL, AS
LAWMAKERS DECIDE THE FATE OF
DACA.
SENDER MARCO RUBIO JOINS US NOW
FROM CAPITOL HILL TO DISCUSS
THOSE AND A LOT OF OTHER ISSUES.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO APPEAR THE
TOPIC OF THE DAY IS THIS
YOU MORE ATTUNED TO THE CURRENT
DURBAN-GRANDMA VERSION OF THE
IMMIGRATION BILL?
OR WERE TO BE CLOSER TO THE
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE CALLED THE
MORE HARD-LINE PEOPLE LIKE TOM
COTTON OR SENATOR PURDUE?
>> I DON'T KNOW THE PROPOSAL
OTHER THAN WHAT BEEN EXPRESSED
WALL AND IMPROVE OUR OVERALL
SECURITY.
I THINK WE SHOULD END THE
DIVERSITY LOTTERY.
I BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD FIGURE
THAT FIND THEMSELVES, OR MANY
OTHER PEOPLE PEOPLE THAT FIND
THEMSELVES NOT UNDER DACA
DESIGNATION.
THE BIG DEBATE HAS BEEN, HOW
DEEP WITH THE ALTOGETHER?
THE PRESIDENT'S NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY OF BORDER SECURITY, THE
FRAMEWORK RIGHT NOW, EACH SIDE
WILL HAVE TO GET SOMETHING.
WHAT ELSE GETS IN THERE HAS BEEN
WITH THE DEBATE HAS BEEN ABOUT.
I SUPPORT ENDING THE DIVERSITY
LOTTERY.
I THINK WE SHOULD ADMIT PEOPLE
TO THE UNITED STATES BASED ON
WHAT THEY WILL CONTRIBUTE TO THE
BASED SYSTEM OF IMMIGRATION.
IT SHOULD BE COUNTRY BASED, IT
SHOULD BE PERSON BASED.
>> Laura: SENATOR, BACK IN
2015, YOU GAVE US SPEECH AT
SEATAC.
YOU SAID I LEARNED BY WESTMONT
IMMIGRATION.
YOUR POINT WAS THAT WE HAVE TO
HAVE TO DO ENFORCEMENT FIRST
BEFORE HE CAN GET TO THE OTHER
PARTS HE SAID.
THAT WAS OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE OF
THE GANG OF EIGHT.
THAT WENT DOWN IN FLAMES.
THERE, WHO TODAY SAID WE NEED
DIFFERENT PARTNERS, WILLING
PARTNERS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
WHAT OF THAT?
THE WHITE HOUSE IS THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THE PRESIDENT RAN ON THE WALL
AND ENFORCEMENT.
>> ANYTHING WE PASS ARE, WE WILL
HAVE TO HAVE HIM SIGN IT.
THAT'S THE ONLY PARTNER AT THE
WAS MORE THAN JUST BORDER
SECURITY FIRST.
IT WAS A STEP-BY-STEP APPROACH
VERSUS A COMPREHENSIVE ONE,
YOU ARE ONLY TALKING ABOUT FIVE
THINGS AND THEY CAN'T PUT IT
TOGETHER.
THAT'S WHAT I LONG BELIEVE YOU
START WITH SECURITY FIRST AND
THAT'S SOMETHING EVERYBODY
SHOULD AGREE ON.
I DON'T KNOW WHY ANYONE SHOULD
ARGUE WHY WE SHOULDN'T SECURE
OUR BORDER AND ENFORCE
IMMIGRATION LAWS.
WHEN YOU GO TO MODERNIZATION
LIKE MAKING A MERIT BASED OR
GETTING RID OF THE DIVERSITY
LOTTERY.
GOING TO A PERSON BASED SYSTEM.
>> Laura: I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT, BUT AREN'T THEY DOING
AMNESTY AT THE SAME TIME MEXICO
THAT EVERYBODY, BUT THEY ARE
DOING 800,000 AT THE SAME TIME.
DO IN 2013, AND THAT OBVIOUSLY
DIDN'T WORK OUT WELL.
THE PRESIDENT IS STILL WILLING
NEGOTIATION IS SAYING, WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE WILL DEAL
WITH THE DACA SITUATION, BUT YOU
HAVE TO DO A STRONG ENFORCEMENT
THAT WILL HAPPEN.
ONE OF THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
NOW AND 2013, YOU HAVE SOMEONE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE THAT PEOPLE
TRUST WILL DO IT.
IT'S A DYNAMIC SHIFT WHERE WE
STOOD AT THIS TIME IN 2013
ARGUING ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
ENFORCEMENT WOULD EVEN HAPPEN,
EVEN IF WE PASSED A LAW THEY
ARGUED IT WOULDN'T HAPPEN.
>> Laura: ARE YOU FOR THAT TO
COME IN?
>> I THINK KEEPING THE NUCLEAR
FAMILY IS ONE THING.
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO CLAIM THEIR
PARENTS OR OTHER RELATIVES IS
NOT SOMETHING I SUPPORT.
TO ME, THAT'S PART OF MOVING
AWAY FROM THE FAMILY BASED
SYSTEM AND TOWARDS THE
MERIT-BASED SYSTEM.
>> Laura: LET'S TALK ABOUT
WHAT JEFF FLAKE IS SAYING
TOMORROW.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF CHARGES.
FIRST TRUMP IS A RACIST COMMENT
WHICH I ASSUME YOU DON'T AGREE
WITH.
>> I NEVER SAW HIM SAY OR DO
ANYTHING IN FRONT OF ME FOR ME
TO BELIEVE HIM.
I CERTAINLY HAVE NEVER VIEWED
HIM THAT WAY.
>> Laura: I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
SIT DOWN IN A ROOM WITH SOMEONE
ONE DAY AND SAY TWO DAYS LATER
HE IS A RACIST.
NOW JEFF FLAKE IS GIVING A
SPEECH TOMORROW WHERE HE IS
COMPARING TRUMP'S TREATMENT OF
PURGE, 28 MILLION DEATHS
ATTRIBUTED TO HIM.
HOW DO WE GET HERE?
>> I DON'T AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
THE PRESIDENT DOES.
I BET YOU YOU DON'T AGREE WITH
WITH OR WOULD HAVE DONE
DIFFERENTLY.
THE REACTION TO IT IS VERY
EXAGGERATED.
WE WILL TO SEE WHAT HE SAYS IN
THE SPEECH TOMORROW.
THERE ISN'T ANY COMPARISON
BETWEEN THIS PRESIDENT OR ANY
AMERICAN WITH JOSEPH STALIN.
HE HASN'T GIVEN THE SPEECH YET
THOUGH.
>> Laura: LET'S TALK ABOUT
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO TO PREVENT
YOUR GOAL, AND WHAT DO YOU
INTEND TO DO.
>> THERE'S CLEARLY A RUSSIAN
PART TWO     TWO A.
MY BIGGER PROBLEM, WE CAN ONLY
DO WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN THE
PAST, LOOKING BACK RETROACTIVELY
PAST, LOOKING BACK RETROACTIVEL
RETROACTIVELY.
THE BIGGEST OR TO AMERICANS
ELECTORAL SYSTEM AND QUITE
FRANKLY AMERICA AT LARGE IS NOT
RUSSIA, IT'S CHINA.
CHINA HAS BASICALLY INFILTRATED
ITS WAY INTO ALL OF OUR
TECHNOLOGIES ACROSS THE SUPPLY
CHAIN.
THEY MAKE ANYTHING THE RUSSIANS
THAT INCLUDES INFLUENCE
INDIVIDUALS IN AMERICAN
THAT INCLUDES POTENTIALLY
IS NOT THE RUSSIANS, EXACTLY THE
CHINESE.
THEY ARE MUCH LARGER WITH A LOT
THOUGHT ABOUT WHEN GETTING
INVOLVED IN THIS LEGISLATION.
OUT TONIGHT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO BE
REVIEWING POSSIBLE PLANS TO
EXPAND OUR MILITARY RESPONSE
WITH NUCLEAR WEAPONS, TWO
POTENTIAL CYBER ATTACKS ON
WATER, COMMUNICATIONS, OTHER
ESSENTIAL SERVICES THAT WOULD
BASICALLY SHUT DOWN THE POWER
OVER REACTION TO THAT WELL.
YOU'LL SEE HEADLINES THAT SAY
TRUMP WANTS NUCLEAR ATTACKS.
THAT'S WHAT      NOT WHAT THIS I
THAT'S WHAT      NOT WHAT THIS
THAT'S WHAT      NOT WHAT THIS B
THAT'S WHAT      NOT WHAT THIS U
IT'S BEEN EXPANDED AND MADE
PUBLIC.
THE BIGGEST THING ABOUT THIS,
YOU TALK ABOUT THESE ATTACKS.
WE TALK ABOUT THINGS THAT WOULD
KNOCK PLANES OUT OF THE SKY AND
KILL PATIENTS IN HOSPITALS,
PARALYZE OUR ELECTRIC GRID.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT MASSIVE
LOSS OF LIFE IF THE KINDS OF
ATTACKS THAT ARE BEING TRIED TO
ANTICIPATED HERE ARE THE ATTACKS
THAT HAPPEN.
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW AHEAD OF
TIME, IF YOU DO THIS, WE ARE NOT
GOING TO HAVE A SERIES OF TOWN
HALL MEETINGS TO TALK ABOUT WHY
THIS HAPPEN.
COUNTRIES KNOW WHAT THE RESPONSE
WILL BE IF THEY WANT A NUCLEAR
ATTACK AGAINST US.
THEY NEED TO NOTE THAT RESPONSE
WOULD BE IF THEY LAUNCH A
LIFE-THREATENING CYBER OR
REGULAR ATTACK.
A LOT OF PEOPLE COUNTRIES MIGHT
NOT HAVE A NUCLEAR CAPABILITY OR
SMALL NUCLEAR CAPABILITY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO EXPAND INTO OUR
TERRITORY.
WE WILL DO A BETTER JOB OF